being independent now that the industry
has changed so much is like are you
having to still kind of i mean you know
the music industry you have very smart
people around you but like
what are the things that you're
practicing now to try to kind of
um repeat the success that you had you
know back then that's a really good
question i think um
the the industry has changed big time i
think back in the day it was about like
brand personality on youtube right
because youtube is a video yeah of this
guy do we think this guy's cool what's
his story what's he look like where's he
from you know like you capture all these
things everybody so heavily on youtube
and now in the streaming era it's kind
of more like all right does this sound
out of these 50 000 songs i listen to
does it capture me and so i think the
name of the game now
is really
focusing on your micro fan base right
your fan base
yeah your fan base is this my fan base
is this like i'm a very famous person
like when i walk yeah your monthly
listeners are [ __ ] huge when i walk
down the street like people are going to
recognize me type [ __ ] now visually
you're also very unique people are like
oh it's the guy with the great hair and
yeah i saw my necklace yeah that's what
i'm talking about yo
so it's here and then but i can't focus
on this in today's world right i have to
focus on this
this smaller amount of people that are
really into everything i do i'm engaged
engaged i need to super serve them
they're buying merch they're they're
buying everything they're they're
keeping things afloat i need to super
serve them and as i'm super serving them
something will raise its hand and then
appeal to all these people that's how
you do it and that's kind of what i
notice in today's independent game it's
because the music is easy to make the
music don't cost nothing to make you
know so it's about dropping as
much quality product as you can to these
people who [ __ ] with you and then if
something breaks out of that awesome
then you're on yeah yeah but those
people are going to keep your lights on
they're going to
exaggerate the bills i always tell every
artist that i'm like yo if you got a
core [ __ ] fan base like
feed them what they want
and then something's going to break
through exactly if you're independent
like it only makes sense like you know
at the end of the day the name of the
game is to
support yourself
off of music straight up support
yourself off of songs and in the
streaming world that's what you do you
upload the song and it immediately
starts paying you in the youtube world
where i came from it's like no you
build as big of a brand as you can and
you go on tour and that's what pays you
music didn't pay nobody right you know
so now it's like and these people love
you
they'll listen to everything so give
them as much as possible and and tap in
with them like i'm on patreon i'm on
twitch i'm on patreon discord i'm on all
that [ __ ] because these people me and
them we are friends i haven't heard of
many artists on patreon so kind of
because obviously in the podcast space
it's a lot of podcasts creators that go
on patreon it's kind of like
only fans but without [ __ ] and tits
exactly yeah it's the only fans without
being hypersexualized
so like if you you know like uh if you
have a dope podcast you might
some people will have be on patreon and
they might do a bonus episode or they
might have like you might get the
episode before everyone else type [ __ ]
how do you use it so what i do is i just
give them the music first
if i have a song that's coming out next
month they have it right now
you know like
not for nothing and i know this is going
to piss people off
they had the album like a day and a half
in advance the whole thing every song
mastered the whole [ __ ] and i gave it to
them first i'm not getting none of them
plays recorded i'm not none of that you
know those streams aren't counting for
anything except for their excitement and
their enjoyment so i try to give them as
much [ __ ] as possible first and you're
monetizing that probably at a better
rate than your monetizing streams
damn yeah straight up yeah fast like
yeah [ __ ] the streams like you these
people are pay how much how much you
charge your money five dollars a month
yeah is there different tiers or just
one there's different tiers so what's
the highest tier i believe the highest
tier is
15
i think
and it just comes with higher levels of
access you know more [ __ ] i can give you
before i can give it to anybody else
that's big getting enough people doing
that there's you know you get enough
people doing that and once again you
don't have to worry about taking no
advance from nobody
you know being in some shitty loan
situation
and really really what it was for me too
is realizing oh i'm massively successful
in music right like
i spy is a billion something stream song
you know maybe going towards two or some
[ __ ] like that
you know playing with me as like almost
500 million streams like hey julie is
another gold or platinum record like
there's massive success
but in order for me to be truly like
rich as [ __ ]
i need to be doing all that [ __ ]
independently by myself
you know it's real that's how you
actually reach like masterpiece status
or somebody like that who's genuinely
wealthy off their music you need to just
do it yourself and in today's world i
have these people who are supporting me
who love me my homies right this is my
family we're going to keep things afloat
no matter what whether i'm up down
sideways and then i have all this
endless amount of music that i can
release without having to go through all
this yellow tape i can just drop record
after record after record and when
something waves its hand to the masses
cool it doesn't all of the money exactly
exactly and all i gotta do is make tick
tocks honestly